just like a take on Titan and other such
anime where the mangaka doesn't have an
attachment to his main cast Jujutsu
Kaiser and shocks us with countless
deaths like there is literally too many
for me to go over every single life form
inside of this story from your most
beloved characters to the ones you hate
you'll be less confused not knowing
who's gonna drop next this list will
make you cry and laugh at the same time
while being shocked with his sheer
multitude of people who are raced from
the juju cars in Universe just how many
deaths did take place in Jesus Kaizen
well there is a lot so sit back and
relax as I also decided to bring in a
multitude of my favorite to Juicy cousin
YouTubers to help me out with this
ridiculous List have you do want similar
content just like this where I'm gonna
bring a bunch of people on from
different series to discuss moments
throughout those series then smash that
like button so that I know you want more
And subscribe if you are new around here
but as I just said sit back and relax as
we get into the first chronological
death introduced to Kaizen
foreign
normally people are dying get buried but
Rika orimoto got hit by a car and turned
into a vengeful cursed Spirit Rika
appeared in Jiu Jitsu Kaizen zero a
prequel to the original story she is
Yuda akotsu's beloved childhood friend
and someone who never truly left this
story even though the movie kind of made
it seem that way as I said Rika arimodo
died in a horrifying car accident
becoming a spirit and eventually
transforming into a special great curse
word called the queen of curses although
reiker had spent years haunting Utah
after Yuda joined Tokyo Jutsu high he
learned several ways to when Rebel
curses that finally allowed rika's
Spirit to rest in peace
[Music]
is honestly a fantastic character who
sadly has one of the biggest downfalls
inside of the series he goes from a
charismatic man who would lay his life
on the line for anybody to a
narcissistic dude who looks down on
anyone he considers below him ghetto
seems to hold strong feelings of hatred
for non-sorcerers to the extent of mass
murdering hundreds of civilians in a
single night because of his outrageous
behavior and twisted morals ghetto got
expelled from Jiu Jitsu high and was
titled to be the worst curse user of all
time while normal people get expelled
for using alcohol or bringing weapons in
anime you get expelled for Exterminating
an entire Village which is fair anyways
in the final moments of their cursed
child Arc ghetto Unleashed chaos by
releasing her spirits and declaring war
on the Jiu Jitsu Sorcerers in a
climactic battle he faces off against
Utah kotsu but is ultimately defeated
and later killed by Gojo satoru but his
body is reanimated by an unknown entity
leading to a new ghetto emerging with
enhanced Powers the shocking death of
ghetto marks a pivotal moment in the
Jujitsu kaisen storyline thank you big
son and until I haven't gone over all of
the important deaths from throughout
Jujutsu Kaizen zero we move forth into
the original storyline of jejusu Kaizen
first up we have the old G himself a man
drenched in mystery and one hell of a
cool Grandpa wasuke itadori also known
as yuji's grandfather from the very
early on it was shown that Graham's kid
about Yuji more than anyone and the same
went for yucci like man's moral compass
revolves around stunning his grandfather
said extremely early on in the series on
that day as he lay in bed and a few
moments before his death grantively
thought to himself that it was sad he
wasn't surrounded by many people
speaking up he advises Yuji to help
people whenever he could and to not be
like him when he dies moments later
usuka isadori passes on inside of the
hospital
hold your horses dear follow before we
go any further I'm gonna thank the big
dogs themselves raid Shadow Legends for
sponsoring this video raid is a
turn-based RPG game which is both free
and available on mobile and PC pretty
much you'll assemble a team of Yorkdale
Champions develop their skills by
getting better sets of armor and weapons
then use them to go up against other
online players or challengers because
I'm a massive World building nerd in
general the fact that these guys have
over 700 unique characters who the
majority of have like in-depth
backstories that allow someone like
myself to lose themselves in is frankly
amazing my favorite if I had to choose
one would be the gorgeous high elf
Elaine her backstory is definitely one
of the more intrepid and goes into the
interesting Dynamic inside of the high
Elven Monarch society as she is
considered someone who might One Day
become Queen so if you want to click my
link and join up currently new players
can get their hands on these Stag Night
one of the best epic Champions around as
well as his skin for him designed by
JonTron so after you click my link down
below to play raid you see promo code JT
skin before October the 7th of course if
you already do Jam raid you can still
get stag Knight and the skin through an
in-game event then on top of that and
until like the 23rd of October Ray takes
on The Monkey King from Chinese
mythology Sun Wukong who has been
introduced as a legendary champion all
you have to do to get him is log in on
seven random days between now and the
23rd of October to get them for free
with all of this exciting stuff and more
coming to raid in the future if you
haven't started playing yet then what
are you even waiting for use my link
down in the description below or scan my
QR code on screen to get insane bonuses
we're talking an epic Champion Knight
errant from the banner Lords faction and
a bunch of other useful things that you
you just need to get started in the game
but anyway back to kicker absolutely
destroy now Souls with all of the deaths
from attitude to Kaizen now I probably
should mention this because it really
does matter in the grand scheme of
things but Yuji itadori's temporary
death I know you were wondering what
Yuji idradori's death like but just
trust me on this one we obviously We
Know It All Happened and usually's first
death did happen when sukuna got a hold
of his body right after our boy
swallowed one of the fingers inside the
juvenile detention center remember when
man literally ripped out yuji's heart
just a taunt Megami who was standing in
front of him well initially we all
thought Yuji would die instantly however
it was revealed that his mind still
existed within the confines of his
bodies in a world there and in an area
that kind of resembles sakuna's domain
Yuji confronted him determined to punish
sakuna for all that he's done stopping
our boy in his tracks though sakuna
proposes a deal to fix yuji's hard more
specifically under a binding vowel now
I'm slightly off track on this whole
video and everything here but this is
important in the grand scheme of things
listen to the conditions offered by the
almighty sukona asukuna is able to beat
Yuji in a battle here the first one
includes being able to use his body as a
host whenever he wants but he isn't able
to hurt anyone anyone at all during that
one minute and the other is that he has
to forget the conversation that happened
between the two of them here Yuji
thinking that he can somehow like win
decide has to throw hands while a green
with sakuna's conditions however at a
fraction of a second usually gets one
shot and because of the conditions he
doesn't even remember this moment next
up Nagi Yoshino also known as The waifu
Mummy or junipay's Mother after dinner
inside of the Yoshino household Nago
falls asleep on the table only to wake
back up and find this weird looking
finger that was placed by a suit and
someone in front of her it's unfortunate
that she literally woke up only to sleep
again for eternity it turns out that a
curse but had been lurking around
shakuna's finger watch after she picked
it up and went to her room well yeah you
can imagine what happened from there on
out crazy thing is that like because
you're passing included curse Barrette
her death is not officially included in
civilian documents but until you too
High's documents it's reported that her
body was found with its lower half
missing and that it's laid out inside
the bedroom with some cold packs and Ice
all around us obviously it's one messed
up saying that we know junipay stumbled
across and of course not so surprisingly
like mother like son
right after the death of his mother Jun
Pei Yoshino sadly became mahito's next
prey June pay Yoshino one of the
students at satu Sakura High School
became friends with our main character
Yuji however before they became friends
June pay fell from ajito's Dirty passive
aggressive tricks the dude was literally
playing with his mind mahito did save
June pay from the bullies one time but
little did he know the consequences that
would evolve from this incident well his
fate was surely a sad one I remember how
the anime played us all for a Fool by
including him in the opening wearing Jiu
Jitsu High clothes only to go and take
him out an episode later before that
happened though and during the clash
between June pay and Yuji a sneaky
someone strolled down some steps and
completely changed the Escape of the
story for RMC of course the malevolent
mahito who'd been lurking around the
school showed up in the middle of a
conversation between Yuji and junpei
only to transform the unsuspecting June
pay with his Idol Transfiguration sadly
junpai turned into some weird
transfigured monster that after a few
moments tragically collapsed at yuji's
feet for age just after his passing
everyone was wondering what could have
happened if June pay hadn't died and
stayed with the sorcerers as his ability
with that jellyfish thing was pretty
freaking sweet to be honest this is also
why I think Jiu Jitsu kaisen is that
good because it doesn't have only one or
two massive character deaths instead
gege is so freaking wild that by the
time the manga ends the only one left
over might just be Yuji it's wild
because you can never expect your
favorite character to be safe and always
need to expect the unexpected thank you
anime anxiety for taking the reins on
that one next up we've got kachazu one
of the two Blood Brothers on the list
have you been sent out on a mission to
retrieve one of sukuna's fingers kachezu
along with his brother encountered jooji
and nobara at the yosohachi bridge
engaging in an intense battle with the
duo khichiso attempted to use his blood
manipulation powers in combination with
his brother ESO however once injured by
novara's black flash the awakened curse
tries to lash back out but was
subsequently taken out but no Barro's
lethal here pin just before that
happened though Yuji had used his black
to blow off eso's arm after seeing
kachisu injured by this same technique
Aesop hopes that his brother is still
somehow alive however he soon senses
naked cheers who had died and apologizes
to choso that he wasn't able to save
their brother suddenly a random flatbed
truck drives past him and knowing that
he probably isn't strong enough to take
down the tutu Sorcerers ISO takes his
chance to grab the car and take a
hostage doesn't mean to safety as the
car drives away ESO plans to heal
himself and get revenge on Yuji and
Obara for kalima's brother but as he
looks over to Wiki chiso is he notices
no Bara and wonders what any world she
could possibly be doing well nubara of
course she was using nothing other than
a resonance technique on the ah that
Yuji had severed previously to inflict
damage to ESO causing him to fall off
the car from its Affairs in that moment
Yuji took the opportunity to end the
helpless cursed womb's life
foreign
one of the students at Rancho girls
junior high and the star plasma vessel
for tenkins merger in 2006. honestly
episode 3 of season 2 and pretty much
season 2 overall was really really good
like it's crazy how good this is and
Rico's death is handled so so well so
the tragic event occurred when Rico got
attacked by the soldiers of Q while
waiting for suguru ghetto and Sato to
Gojo after being rescued by ghetto and
Gojo Rico joined them in their mission
to protect and Safeguard tengin a
powerful curse object known as the star
plasma vessel however the enemy captured
Rico's friend misato during their
Journey leading to a rescue operation in
Okinawa after successfully saving misato
Rico and ghetto head further into the
tomb to find tengen in the tomb's main
chamber Rico expressed her desire to be
with everyone instead of merging with
tengan and tragically she got shot in
the head by toji fushiguro leading to
her death it's not so much surprising
but it is really sad bad and it does tie
into why ghetto became such a creams I
mean racist and why he became so
disillusioned with the sorcerer world
thank you my uh my freak of a friend
busham zero for taking that now I I hope
you have fun editing this video and
don't do anything crazy to me for just
calling you a freak there but you know
you are a YouTuber so it you know I
don't know what I just
anyway
[Music]
toji or should I say my dad any hottest
villain in the history of anime wait
maybe I'm more of a freak either way
he's he's one hell of a remarkable
character who's caused a bunch of
tragedies and is the strongest
non-sorcerer entity in the entirety of
judicizing are possibly Marky now during
the final moments of the mission for the
time vessel Association instead of
escaping toji notices that the Gojo he
was sure he killed earlier stood right
in front of him and one of toji's
biggest elves of the entire series he
decides to stay and fight of course he
literally decimated Gojo the first time
around so you can't entirely blame him
for wanting to stick around here and do
it again still this summer he allowed
his hatred for Jujutsu sorceress to get
the best of him sadly and as we all have
been witness to now in the anime Gojo
came back absolutely cracked out of his
mind and used the fusion of both of his
Limitless techniques using a mixture of
blue and red goju created for the first
time in his life Hollow purple a
devastating ability that erases anything
from existence and its path blasting it
forth and almost at a point-blank range
toji's left side of his body is utterly
annihilated leaving him there completely
perplexed with the decisions that drove
him to this end but you know Giga wasn't
done at that point he wanted to spares
or toji just just a little more and
after reincarnating throughout the
middle of the freaking Shibuya incident
art what you're gonna get again like I
can't wait until we see this part
animated toji only has one thing on his
mind and that is to destroy the
strongest opponent he can find after
beating Eno to a pulp in Indian old
hagg's existence toji bursts into
dagon's own domain and obliterates the
special great curse in a matter of
moments who by the way was on the very
verge of taking out a bunch of sorcerers
then like like man was on demon time
when he got reincarnated he started to
fight any battle against his own son who
doesn't even realize like it's his dad
right here like oh my Lord this stuff
was so insane and after almost taking
out his son a few times throughout their
small battle he manages to somehow get a
hold of his body stopping it and like
the sir Alleyway for a moment he asked
his son what his name was and when Mega
me said for shiguro toji within a single
second of hesitation stabbed himself off
in the head with a playful Cloud ending
his reincarnation even though like we
might not expect empathy or compassion
from toji just due to who he was in
general him realizing that his son took
his name and was probably raised by Gojo
like Gojo like he asked Gojo in his last
seconds gave him enough faith that he
didn't need to be around any longer and
that's why I think he did what he did
here but maybe you know like with all
the current happenings with megamindi
manga if dude does come back now which
is extremely unlikely it would actually
have a reason to stick around and save
his boy's soul but that's just you know
like one of Noah's theories yeah he's a
little bit mental there when I give him
that
foreign
who in my eyes is like junipay but
cooler because he almost gets to save
ghetto we're talking to Jutsu you high
Barra might be one of the minor
characters who we only got a few moments
of or like panels from in general but he
truly played a crucial role in building
the character development of Canton Army
and kiddo sometime after the events that
happened with the star plasma vessel
like I think this was around a year
later corrects me if I'm wrong here the
anime episode hasn't come out yet you
and an army were given a mission to take
out a low ranking curse Spirit however
everything went wrong it turned out that
the info they were given about the curse
Spirit was dead wrong and with it having
taken a role as a kind of deity in the
village it grew in power becoming at
least a grade one threat which
eventually you know took out you we
don't know how it happened but losing
his close friend hits the Nami hard and
is never the same again he drops the
whole Jiu Jitsu sorcerer gig and becomes
your average office worker after he
loses faith in the jijusu society to a
lesser extent this also happens as well
with ghetto but obviously he doesn't
drop out he just loses Faith you was
like definitely the Eugene of the year
and just brought brightness to those
dark times so to see him pass shrouded
ghetto and even more Darkness
foreign
group and for an unspecified time and
secret was teamed up with the Manassas
of the series this technically wasn't
because he wanted to betray everyone so
you have to understand that like
kikichi's character will grow with you
guys and it grew with me throughout this
art profoundly like just stick
yourselves in his shoes for a second and
imagine being crippled your entire life
never been able to touch your friends
with that excruciating pain didn't offer
through binding vowel to become whole
again and offer to finally be there to
help your friends came up one that would
100 work would you shy away from there
or would you take it well this was the
inner conflict that kakichi dealt with
for a while and after fulfilling the
conditions of The Binding vowel and
gaining a healthy body for the first
time in his life he put his new life on
the line to try and save his friends
before the main event of Shibuya this
whole fight was like absolutely amazing
and you got to check out my highlights
Channel if you want to watch all the
fights individually without searching
through an eight hour long Banger of
video but there at the dam kakichi uses
his ultimate mikamaru puppet to blow
everything to birds and was planning to
help by letting Gojo know about the plan
they had set for him in Shibuya however
it didn't take long for mojito to get
the upper hand throughout the battle he
uses his domain expansion and after some
insane uses of simple domain which by
the way he wasn't even meant to know
this technique like he actually learns
it in secret which is super dope kokichi
sadly bites the dust and is ultimately
transfigured by mojito still way
anesthetically privy to those final
moments so man must have been
annihilated in some terrible off-screen
kill instead all we see is the ultimate
mikamaro Gundam slumped over the dam
oh
moving forward into the Shibuya incident
our economy along with a bunch of the
other curse goons unfortunately crossed
paths with Gojo resulting in an intense
battle in which we lose the genderless
tree upon encountering Gojo satru it
becomes clear that defeating the
strongest Sorcerer of all time is no
simple task because he is literally him
man is on a completely different level
when it comes to hands and nothing the
four curses throw at him seemed to work
at all in the end Gojo tricked Hanami
into removing his domain amplification
by making him think he had accidentally
deactivated his curse technique not even
realizing the mistake of their ways
economy goes to use his cursed power but
jogo tells harami to not deactivate his
amplification suddenly Gojo grabs a hold
of the branches on hanami's head and
pulls them out severely weakening the
cursed Spirit chozo from nearby manages
to distract Gojo for a fraction of a
second allowing his teammates to dive in
for an attack however Gojo uses this
moment his advantage and as he activates
his curse technique he crushes the weak
economy up against the wall you already
know that jalamoth had to cover the
insect characters that yegeys blessed us
with starting with the grasshopper curse
the smartest character in Jujutsu Kaizen
he's running all of Japan's fear of
locusts and grasshoppers pulled into one
being mahito gave him the oh so
important job of protecting the curtain
while Yuji and him do have a pretty
thrilling back and forth between two
arms and forearms he doesn't even get a
single hit on Yuji before being
off-screened by the demon god so thank
you uh Jello and big fake way for taking
those two but now we got the old heck
herself ogami a sorcerer and assassin
who could shape-shift people and maybe
even herself using her curse technique
but tragedy struck when her grandson
Saul fell under the dominance of no one
other then toji fushigiro's domineering
Spirit atop one of the buildings in
Shibuya toji Unleashed his wrath on
purogame calling her an old hag and
delivering a devastating punch that
ultimately blew through any defense they
thought they had defenseless against his
Onslaught ogami met her untimely fight
and died there
next up we've got Nikita bana who is is
probably one of the characters you
easily forget the name of but during the
Shabu incident art niji emerged as one
of the Allied cursed users and the suedo
Guido's command the intense clash
between niji and meimei who's actually
insanely skilled shitsu sorcerer
unfolded when niji a company by
formidable curse Spirit confronted her
and her tame in the heart of Shibuya as
the battle escalated between two mame's
unyielding assault pushed niji into a
state of desperation causing blood to
stream from his nose despite niji's
pleas for Mercy men may sternly question
his comprehension on the value of Life
having listened to his reply and
immediately becoming dissatisfied with
his feeble response she struck a fatal
blow abruptly terminating The Clash and
snuffing out this dude's life
next up digon is one of those
unregistered special gray cursed Spirit
who have joined hands with mojito jogo
and Hanami what's different about this
man is that you often see this squad
actually hanging out in its domain
expansion Horizon of the captivating
skanda Judah was overconfidence and
belief in himself Dagon underestimated
humans a little too much which resulted
in his tragic death at the hands of no
one other than big daddy Koji for
shiguro so after Reviving through
ogami's Seance technique as I've like
been over before Koji only sought one
thing and that was the destruction of
anyone who we considered strong
throughout the like landscape of Shibuya
and most likely finding a partially
formed hole on the ground outside of
dagon's domain which by the way was
currently in use against the plethora of
Jujutsu High Sorcerers Koji made his
magnificent reappearance falling into
this foreign World Koji within a few
milliseconds changes the other Outlook
of this previously fleeting battle due
to how toji was reanimated he
immediately went off the strongest
around human or curse and of course this
happens to be the special great demon
Dagon Dagon tells Last Breath try to
resist his unfortunate fate claiming
that the battle is not over until it's
over toji though as in held down by the
chains of Fate before Marky even
realized what had happened toju stolu's
special grade weapon playful Cloud
sharpened both of its points as if it
was a plane stick an exercise to gone
and one brutal display of dominance
diving out of the domain now though now
because then the head honcho of the
Xenon family and Naomi is dead was a
total badass special grade one shiutu
sorcerer his curse technique is focused
on projection sorcery where he divides
one second into 24 frames with anything
it touches must abide by 24 FPS roll or
it will get Frozen for one second inside
the animation frame on that fateful
October the 31st and literally right
after toji took out to God before they
could even catch their breath jungle
showed up and tragically ended naobito's
life as he was burned to a crisp in a
matter of seconds there's been some
hectic deaths I'd love to know your
thoughts on like all of the Decks that
have happened throughout the series so
far and the stuff that we've got to come
through our Shibuya as next up
[Music]
the twins with Innocent faces but much
more deceiving personalities throughout
the heart of Shibuya like this is
definitely where we are first graced
with the god-given talent of Giga
akutami to physically break our souls
Gojo who got sealed a little while back
was really only a front to the true
destruction of what is to come here with
Yuji line helpless on the floor after a
succession of battles he was in himself
the girls find and began feeding him a
finger in order to revive sakona so you
see in their eyes if they revive sakuna
they can use his body to help take out
the body swapper and get ghetto back so
as he Toes that to feed Yuji sukuna's
fingers Joko randomly shows up as well
instantly and following the destructive
path that jogo was just on with everyone
else he takes care of them in a moment
and continues to feed sakuna some more
fingers to be exact I think he had like
11 of them or something anyway anyway
nanaku manages to heal the two and they
prepare to fight jogo themselves but
suddenly sukuna awakens while telling
jogo to move standing above the girls as
they bow terrified on the floor asks
what they want since they did feel my
finger apparently they want to use him
to free their trapped Master though he
takes offense and decides to end him
first he tells the girls to raise their
heads though then with a cheeky grin on
his face he takes nanako by surprise as
he obliterates mimiko who was sitting
right next to her shocked with what just
happened nanako tries to pull out her
phone to fight back but before she's
even able to take a picture she too is
vaporized from existence by sukunas
cleave technique
driven by a shared desire among many
cursed Spirits jogo sought the
destruction of humanity envisioning a
world where cursed Spirits ruled he was
the reason now Obito Zenon died in
winonomy and monkey got severely injured
in the Shibuya incident art however his
Grand dreams were tragically cut short
when he came across sukuna the king of
curses jogo unlike mimiko and nanako
didn't ask sukuna for any favors and
only told him to try to take over yudi's
body permanently tsukuna refused and
revealed he had his own plans confusing
and surprising jogo as an appreciation
for the fingers tsukuna agreed to throw
hands with his special grade curse and
if he lost then he would follow his
plans instead jogo willingly engaged
with tsukuna in the hopes of recruiting
him knowing full well he could die in
the process as the two Titans fought
jogo was heavily outclassed by tsukuna
and was once again forced to realize his
own weakness frustrating him throughout
the fight in the end while the two stood
atop jogo's Maxim meteor tsukuna showed
him something that we still barely have
any knowledge on in the series the Black
Box and after opening this box and
creating some form of hellish fire in
his palm tsukuna shoots it forth utterly
annihilating the special great courage
from reality in a fraction of a second
one minute he's standing on top of
Maximum meteor and Shibuya then the next
he is strolling through the afterlife as
if he's been there for hundreds of years
appearing himself in this otherworldly
area sukuna believed jogo was foolish
for wanting to take the place of humans
he told jogo that flocking together and
comparing yourself to those around you
stuns true growth and that jogo should
have burned everything he desired to
send her without a second thought even
still sukana admitted that their fight
was fun for him stating that jogo stood
out amongst those he had fought in the
last Thousand Years encouraging the
curse Spirit to stand proud because he
was strong this acknowledgment of his
strength made jogo so proud that he shed
tears for the first time in his short
life completely unaware he was even
capable of crying sorry guys I didn't
have enough breath after a memo
but next up we literally have everyone's
favorite character and the entirety of
the Jews are Carson Universe luck
incarnate haruta shiggy Mo okay you know
I'm obviously joking stuff this man he's
like an actual disease and he's probably
my least favorite character or the one I
hate the most kind of like Joffrey from
Game of Thrones he's on identity of life
which is a good thing for characters and
anyway still on October 31st in Shibuya
things got seriously intense
he's in my eyes more hated than even
mojito following the orders of the
mysterious Aroma who just showed up
randomly throughout this part of the
story haruto launched a full-on attack
on the assistant managers who were
helping the juju Sorcerers but guess
what after doing this he ended up
Crossing past with no one other than the
Fierce and determined nopara who was
accompanied by the badass manager akari
Nita sadly and mainly because shigamo is
actually an average sorcerer he was able
to get the upper hand on the two ladies
just before he was going to strike down
on one of them though Our Big G and Nami
suddenly arrived and beat him to a pulp
however and I guess because of this
dude's likability he somehow survived
this absolutely insane beat down after
he eventually woke back up through his
path unexpectedly crosses with migami
foshiguro who in a moment of utter
desperation summons maharaga to defeat
him sukuna who had just won his nearby
battle against jogo notices that
freaking maharaga was summoned and
decided to stroll over to fix the
situation having shown up and Blitz
maharaga in a matter of moments himself
Sakura Chucks the wheel aside and
watches her disintegrate which also
signifies the conclusion of the exorcism
ritual and that there I can tell you has
a massive roles to play later on in the
story anyway seeing shigumo and the
vicinity he tells the curse user to be
gone pompy shikamo to flee and joy
however he was not safe from malevolent
shrine's effects like Mega me was and
because this dude ran the wrong way well
take it in by surprise with a delayed
effect sugar most body slides apart
having been completely sliced in half by
zikuna's cleave
foreign
may your soul rest in peace my good
friend now he is undoubtedly one of the
most cherished characters and she's due
to Kaizen capturing fans hearts with his
incredible ability to ratio the absolute
fog out of anyone he comes across let
the dude is literally the reason this
channel exists at start with if I wasn't
stuck in a terrible job at the time and
didn't Vibe with this dude's personality
I probably would still be laying
concrete like I used to back in the past
so when I first really head into Shibuya
after season one this moment freaking
broke my heart and the Shibuya incident
like the majority of the deaths are
throughout the series The Nami finds
himself bedded and bruised facing a
swarm of mutated humans after he thought
did gone and was also burned by Joko but
you know what he's not even one to back
down from all of that despite his
injuries his thoughts Linger on Megami
Maki and naobito worrying about this
safety amidst the chaos pushing forth an
army fights fiercely taking down a
multitude of new set of humans one by
one but facing
appears and offers a chilling
conversation and a surreal turn nanami
sees his long-lost friend you pointed
towards no one other than Yuji who had
also just showed up with the
determination nanami passes the torch to
Yuji saying that he's got it from here
and instant mahiro obliterates hanami's
upper body ending his journey and the
story
now some of you are going to sit back
and be like bro she ain't dead well I
don't see a round on the series anymore
do you guys like like damn this moment
always breaks me but here you get
another one of the most heartbreaking
moments in all of Shonen with the
apparent death of nobira kukasaki so if
we all remember back to when I first
mentioned that she was almost taken out
by Sugar Mo well after being told to
leave by nanami dear nobara makes a
decision herself to return and do what
she can to help in fighting the cursors
sadly for her the one curse she ends up
in an exchange with happens to be no one
other than the ever-evolving speech
where curse Spirit mojito employing her
ability nabara sends multiple Nails
flying then the heiso Dodges them he's
in a full-on sign Novara gets close
enough to attack Mojito's clone with
their hairpin technique initially it
seems that mojito has the upper hand on
her only to be shocked when nobara's
resonance ability attacks his soul
directly the damage remove Barrow's
attacks on the Clones resonates with the
original and bounces back to the Clone
leaving both of them stunned having been
caught off guard manito's vulnerability
allows Yuji to also launch a rush of
punishing blows to deal with this crisis
both Mojitos flee from their respective
battles while forcing the enemies to
follow suddenly the two Mojitos run past
each other in the subway hallway not
returning back into one like originally
suspected you see when the two Mojitos
crossed paths it means that no Barrel
would be placed up against the real
mojito another clone that she was
originally fighting the devil rushes
towards Yuji for the original having
darted 4th touches a confused nobara's
face who was like by the way just round
in a corner so she didn't exactly know
what she was running into and the exact
same moment Yuji manages to take out a
clone but sadly with mojito touching our
girl's face it leaves only one possible
outcome powerless to intervene Yuji
could only watch in horror as nobara's
life flashes before her eyes stand in
there she tells Yuji to say to everyone
that her life it wasn't so bad before
sadly her face is manipulated by
Mojito's transfiguring technique
shattering her features and destroying
one of her eyes
meso well this man is something else
isn't he he's one of those like kind of
hoe villains in the world of Kaizen who
takes out a bunch of your favorite
characters like nanami look Barra or
junipay all out while playing an
extremely crucial role as a kind of like
initial bad guy that our MCA is trying
to take down I absolutely love mojito
throughout like this part of the story
in general he's just like that dude you
hate for the the sole reason of needing
to hate him because you want the MC to
take him down he allied with like suedo
ghetto and assembled a group of powerful
curses including jogo Hanami and Dagon
together the four of them shared a
common objective the eradication of
humanity and the domination of the World
by curse Spirits NATO really wanted to
achieve his goal of obliterating
humanity and he went to Great length to
achieve it he manipulu curses distorted
souls and caused widespread chaos his
powers allowed him to deform and reshape
his own body along with the bodies of
the innocent and even the strong juicy
Sorcerers NATO's actions instilled fear
and posed a grave threat to the Jews
whose Sorcerers and almost any civilian
throughout Japan now let's talk about
who actually took out mojito because all
my Lord gig it was a next little cut on
this one after what is like I I don't
know like just straight up yuji's
greatest battle and you use your Kaizen
so far where he and his brother big Toto
team up and the final moments of the
Shibuya incident to take out mojito well
towards the end of that fight Yuji
evolved into an utter beast man was on
pure demon time like he was full on
tracking mojito as if he was a fox
across the ground as the pathetic
curseberg crawled and sprawled for his
safety and a Twist of faith that no one
expected mojito terrified ran to the
feet of no one other than kinjaku or the
fake sudokito then as mojito coward
asking for him to save him kinjaku took
his opportunity to enact his true goal
and killed mojito by turning him into an
ore with his cursedberg manipulation
even though it's not clearly mentioned
where the Mojito died or not one thing's
for sure is that after kinjaku used his
Country-Wide Idol Transfiguration mojito
most likely faded away from reality
thank you
so next up the principal at Tokyo Jiu
Jitsu High and the man who managed to
bring a freaking doll to life masamichi
Yaga masumi masamiji Yaga is one of the
people who understand Gojo Saturday more
than anybody else and in my eyes almost
took on a fatherly role for him being
sturmany needed to be but also allowing
him to grow Yaga at Jiu Jitsu sorcerer
with an extraordinary curse technique
found himself in a perilous situation
after the Shibuya incident the high raps
in the jihutsu world issued a death
sentence for him driven not only by his
apparent involvement and the incident
through being ghetto and Gojo's teacher
but also by the Intrigue surrounding his
unique powers after everyone is given
their respective punishments for Shibuya
masamichi is seen alone walking along a
street when a Jujutsu higher up Suddenly
appears atop a light pole and confronts
him asking where he's going without any
cursed corpses masumichi tells them that
he's going to say goodbye to his son but
the higher up tells him that the only
other way to save himself as if he tells
him how to make independent curse
corpses knowing that they became more
active after Gojo ceiling masamichi is
then taken by surprise as gakuganji off
screens him in a matter of moments
leaving him laying there severely
wounded a little while later and out of
completely nowhere as gakuganji stood
above him masamichi then explains the
process on how to create an independent
curse corpse confused yakuganji asks
masumichi why he didn't reveal this
information before he was Faithfully
wounded and massive me she replies that
this was a curse from him tekakuganji a
few moments later Panda then arrives and
sensing him dakuganji prepares for a
fight but Panda ignores him and rushes
towards his father cradling his deceased
body
my Zenon is maki's twin sister and it's
because they're twins that they were
belittled by everyone in the Zenon Clan
well because they're twins and also
because they're women anyway Twins were
seen as unlucky in Jiu Jitsu society and
there's a reason for that myanmaki share
Soul Maki was born with Heavenly
restriction and more or less no cursed
energy at all and my even though
technically having a curse technique
could hardly make use of it because of
her diminished amounts of cursed energy
despite their oppressive upbringing
somehow my despite how often she said
she hated Maki has always held on to the
belief that someday through maki's
resilience and strength the Zenon Clan
and all the suffering that came with it
would be destroyed during the perfect
preparation Arc we follow Maki down into
the tunnels of the Zen and Clan compound
upon entering the warehouse Maki finds
her father ogi awaiting her arrival and
behind him bleeding on the floor is my
calling Maki an idiot and asking why she
showed up even now not asking for
anything from her big sister and after
making quick work of Maki Ogie drags
both girls down the hall and throws them
into a pit of curses to be finished off
maki's organs hanging out and Mai on the
edge of death herself chooses this last
moment to finally show her sister what's
in her heart after sinking together into
what I assume is the curse realm or the
girls innate domain Maya explains to
Maki The Impossible truth of their
existence saying as long as I'm around
you Maki will never fully develop one
soul and two bodies we then witness
Maya's heartbreaking sacrifice as she
walks into the ocean while promising
Maki that she'll take the cursed energy
and everything to death with her
turning around only to leave behind one
thing a sword whose construction would
cost her the remnants of her life when
maki's eyes open back in reality Maya is
no longer breathing and maki's body is
no longer broken My Sacrifice became
maki's Awakening a woman with absolutely
zero cursed energy no longer tied to the
chains of Fate this painful moment just
shows how much unwavering love Mai had
for her sister to think the person that
we originally met at the beginning of
the series would sacrifice herself for
someone we thought she hated her death
is like I said also the reason why Maki
was able to complete her Heavenly
restriction the first to exist after
toji Zenon but Mai also left behind her
will a will to destroy the zening clan a
will that Maki carries out to Perfection
thank you Liv for taking the reins on
that one and honestly everyone go and
check out Lou's Channel as well she does
like kind of similar content to what I
do with talking just about stories and
all of that kind of stuff in general you
know I just think it's great she goes
over all like the light novels for
Jujutsu Kaizen and deserves a lot more
love if you just want to sit back and
find out what happens with those moving
forth and talking about the Zen and Clan
and technically right off the previous
moment that love just went over and a
surprising turn of events allowed Mahi
to slay the curse spirit and emerge Anew
thanks to her now achieving the same
superhuman physical abilities as your
cousin toji for shiguro noticing the
sudden disappearance of the curse Spirit
Augie tunes that didn't see Maki emerge
funny room with mice body and her arms
after seeing his daughter Okie is
immediately filled with the same dread
he felt from Koji in the past each also
sword and activates his inner eight
technique to fight her once again but
before he even realizes she quickly
slices his head in half and begins to to
Forte and to destroy the entire Xenon
Clan so next up on marky's Forte and to
destroying the entire Zenith Clan the
kukuru unit led by Captain novawaki was
a specialized Squad within the Xenon
Clan their main duty was to enforce the
Clan's orders and maintain control over
its members all of you members of the
squad don't have their own innate
technique and are a lower branch of the
hay which itself is a section of the
Xenon household and also just for
further information Mikey also used to
be a part of this kukuru unit after
dispatching her father Marquee then
proceeded to take down the kukuru squad
by defeating each member individually
with precise strikes and incredible
agility she swiftly incapacitated her
opponents delivering fatal blows that
left no room for Mercy the members of
the kokuru unit made a violent end
unable to withstand marky's Relentless
attacks and in matter of moments Maki
emerged Victorious leaving her
Battlefield stewing with Fallen foes
they say your arrogance is the key to
your demise and it's certainly true and
This Man Called chojiro xenon's case has
he seemed pretty overconfident while
fighting Marquee his curse technique is
called Earth arms which is dope and it's
kind of like Toth from Avatar and allows
him to manipulate the Earth's terrain to
some degree and his battle with Marky he
proved to be a bit too much of a foe
though and in one swift move she tore
out chojiro's throat permanently
silencing the old Fogle the Zen and
family part of the story as I've just
gone over beforehand has garnered
significant hype and for good reason
they were a force to be reckoned with
and one of the big three family
structures used to Kaizen but within a
few hours probably there's been hours
within a few minutes that all changes
magnificent members of the family
jinichi Xenon was no exception his curse
technique allows him to make giant fists
propelled by curse energy like a missile
when the news of Okies in his demise
reached jinichi he made the ill-fated
decision to confront Maki along with the
other members of the Haye as anticipated
this proved to be the greatest mistake
of his life and a display of her
formidable prowess Maki swiftly
demolished janichi standing atop his
massive fist in delivering a decisive
blow that left no room for Escape next
up we've got rantha Xenon another member
of these hidden family's Elite unit who
showed some potential as a semi-grade
one sorcerer throughout Marquis
destruction of his inning Clan household
run to eagerly jumped into action to
fight against her he tried to hold her
down using his paralyzing curse
technique where he can immobilize anyone
he looks at but oh boy Mahi effortlessly
broke through his curse technique was
sheer Brute Force poor ranta like could
not handle the hate at all and as his
strength started to disappear his curse
technique put a lot of strain on his
eyes causing him to go blind tragically
as he used up more of his energy his
strength waned and due to him losing his
sight Ryan he ended up dying falling to
the ground thinking that they won
[Music]
ah so we've got everyone's favorite Neo
you Xenon man Navy thought he was hot
stuff but guess what his arrogance just
got a one-way ticket to the afterlife or
should I say misogyny that's definitely
more misogyny than arrogance he's got a
bit of both peppered in there and I'll
just say that to piss off a few of the
Tate lovers out there eh go Super Saiyan
in front of a waterfall or something
that's over here well I guess he
did have reasons to slightly be arrogant
after all because he is a special grade
one Sorcerer And he did inherit the
projection sorcery of neobito Marquee
fueled by Vengeance though and a taste
for justice decided to serve naoya a
hefty portion of humble pie for the
first time in his life as an area's
fancy projection Source tree attacks
failed to save his story behind maku
dodged each and everyone gracefully and
successfully while proceeding to beat
down on him like every other member of
the clan so far however Maggie wasn't
the only one who finished him off in
fact an accused roundabout way to a
moment earlier on in this series it was
actually my I and marky's mother who
stabbed him in the back as he tried to
crawl away to safety but he didn't tie
that easily like you literally have to
expect people like nayoya and shigimo to
survive multiple near-death experiences
flashing into the moments that happened
inside of the sakurajima colony now
which is way up into this culling game
Saga it's shown that he eventually
became a cursed womb who for a short
time managed to overpower Marquee with
his speed however Marquis with the help
of this random culling game members who
show up and lend her a hand Maki
eventually defeats him again even after
his domain expansion was used obviously
this is because like toji when you know
good old naoya brought up his domain
there Mikey is seen as like a
building-like object because it would
lack of curse energy so it never even
knew she was inside of the domain and
she was just able to walk around freely
like she only plays now yeah like every
other helpless naoyo fan attempted to
call Maki a toji imposter when this did
happen but before he was able to finish
his sentence he was destroyed by her
finishing blow
while the rest of the Xenon Clan Maki
and mice mum hated them but it was
mainly because they didn't follow any
plan's ways at some point in the past
she did truly love them back before
every Zen and death that we just went
over before happened though she tried to
stop Maki from reaching my eye but Maki
just didn't listen to her and continued
forth when Mikey finally does defeat
hayoya she goes back to their household
and sees her mother scared in the
kitchen Maki asks their mother why she
asked you to come back like referring to
before as your mother doesn't answer
Markie continues to walk forth and
seemingly cuts her down however she
didn't die instantly as mentioned before
she was the one who eventually finished
off nayoya and it was there on his back
that she eventually succumbed to her
wombs
Harry harai chizuru I don't know how to
say his name properly simply known as
one of the participants of the culling
game as aligned with Reggie Stars grew
after failed negotiations with Megami
early on in the game Shizu attacked him
but was swiftly thrown off the building
and slammed into the crown by no way
despite this setback she usually managed
to survive and even climbed back up to
face mikami once more inside an
apartment chizuru's second attempt ended
in defeat as he was once again thrown
off the building tragically he suffered
a fatal stair by migami upon landing on
the ground as well resulting in his
untimely Demarcus speaking of registar
Reggie was one of the first major
antagonists we were introduced to at the
start of the culling game unlike some of
the characters we didn't get much of a
backstory on Reggie although it's clear
he had a prior relationship with kenjaku
and was acquainted with him well enough
to know the brain clearly had ulterior
motives with this death game Reggie
proves that he's an OG sorcerer by
having a pure blooded con artist and
trick Mercury based sorcery battle with
fushiguro Megan in a fight based around
who can deceive the other better
Reggie's curse technique contractual
Recreation is perfect for that when
burning some kind of proof of purchase
like a receipt or transaction
certificate Reggie can bring whatever
was written on the contract into
existence he uses this to recreate
simple things like a stalk of daikon or
two literal Mack Trucks on Maximum
Overdrive acceleration in the end though
Reggie was bested by Megami who managed
to create his first full domain
expansion by using the walls in the
gymnasium the fight takes place in both
brought to complete exhaustion Reggie is
taken by surprise by megami's Divine dog
totality losing a pretty large chunk of
his body in the attack which ends up
bringing him to defeat as Reggie lies
awaiting the end he makes good on his
promise to Mega me and transfers his 41
points onto him Reggie's one final
request is for Mega me to continue being
a fool and let fate toy with him until
he dies and yeah I think it's fair to
say Reggie wasn't too far off from the
truth
kurorushi are very similar being in
nature to the grasshopper curse is The
manifested insectoid Apparition
representing Japan's fear of cockroaches
it runs entirely on Instinct a
terrifying and ancient force of the
swarm of flying cockroaches that will
devour anything alive kurorishi
asexually reproduces 24 7 which leads to
this constant insatiable appetite for
the taste of iron this hellish creature
meets its bloody end when yutu gives him
a mind-blowing kiss the silver tongue
devily is but while this seemed dire at
the time Kuro was revealed to have
survived this ordeal when he showed up
uninvited to the triple domain expansion
we found out that he can't die unless
all of his cockroach subordinates are
killed which makes him effectively
Immortal since he probably always keeps
one or two hidden away underground but
this entry isn't null and void because
thousands to millions of bugs did die
and these are technically separate
incarnations of the bug man which
implies that he was killed in some way
even if he came back and probably will
again if I wanted to get real technical
about these bugs I could have talked
about all the flyheads we've seen get
vaporized throughout this series as well
but I think I've spoken enough about
jjk's Creepy crawlies so what's up next
let's go back to diabolo by the way
thank you to big no operator and Jayla
moth for taking those two there their
you know channels will be linked down
everyone's channel will be linked down
below anyway moving forth we've got Yoda
Zoo who was another of the reincarnated
sorceress from over a thousand years ago
there they obviously made a deal with
kinjaku to take part in this massive
death battle sadly for Mega me the body
that was chosen for her Revival just
happened to be his sister tsukumis I
don't know can you can you specifically
choose bodies I can't remember if you
could because did kinjaku specifically
choose her I don't know I'd like you
guys to let me know down in the comment
section below if that is possible either
way in the past she was a powerful
sorcerer but had an untimely death
because she was simping too hard on
tsukona and the present she's back at it
again and stronger than ever now she
proposes Kona there if she defeats him
they'll get married huku's technique is
actually construction where she could
recreate any substance she recognized
just like Mai's but a thousand times
better Tunes out love wasn't really for
her as in the end she was a gang
defeated by sakuna in an almost
identical Fashion To The Past even still
that made her happy and she passed on
with a smile on her face
last but like definitely not actually
the last like I'm gonna have to redo
this video for a third time now as I did
like a year and a half ago but this man
has the highest curse energy output in
the history of sorcery fight the gold
Ryu ishigori throughout the cullingham
Saga he fought a three-way battle
against Yuta akotsu into kakoro it was
honestly probably one of the best fights
in Jesus Kaizen when it went all out and
three of them activated their domain
expansion simultaneously it was just
beautiful he though was eventually
defeated by Yuta but he managed to
survive that part of the colony and sort
of became friends with you towards the
end of it I liked their little sit down
chat they had that there is until he met
sakona yes after taking out Yoda zoo and
in preparation to take out Gojo shakuna
decided to slow things down and take out
one of the most beloved culling game
entrance having felt a tremendous flare
of curse energy Ryu prepares himself for
the force that awaited him surprisingly
after sakuna showed up and actually
slashed him across the chest Ryu managed
to survive the first one and even
prepared to shoot off his own ability
however before he was able to shoot
sakuna darted 4th and triple sliced his
face up which yeah man got done it was I
was so sad when I saw Ryu go here I was
like damn I wish he had like reverse
curse technique or something so he could
come back because he was such a cool
character and I really liked how his
character like communicated with YouTube
a lot throughout their art either way if
you guys have enjoyed this video do make
sure you go down into the description
and check out all of the other channels
and the people who have like jumped on
this video as that's a lot of work just
recording a tiny little section for a
video like this and then sending it over
to me it might not seem like a lot but
you know taken out of everyone's day
when they've got like jobs and all that
kind of stuff to do so it does mean a
lot make sure you go check them out and
if you do want more stuff like this what
other series and I'll go and try and get
other YouTubers from different series
and all that kind of stuff then let me
know down below and if you are new
around here and just want to keep up to
date with like massive explained videos
that I usually do then make sure to
subscribe again thanks to Ray for
sponsoring this video make sure you
click my link down below to like jam out
and get a bunch of goodies and whatnot
by the way for now it's been your
professional degenerate diavolo and I'll
see you all in a bit bye